Israel need to do like this you see now
Gaza like this Gaza need to do like
[Music]
this we want to establish an amazing
Masjid for the sake of Allah subhana
tala in the country of Norway click on
the link and donate now for the sake of
Allah subhana
waala brothers and sisters and dear
friends I came across a video in New
York where there was a protest
pro-israeli protest and I just want you
guys to just think for a second or watch
this video and just imagine for a second
if I was to say the following statements
which I have to give you guys a
disclaimer that this is not what I
believe but imagine if I said that we
want Israel wiped out clean like
basically ethnic cleansing and the way
we are talking like look at these
individuals who are at these protest and
they have no shyness they are not
holding it back they are very very Frank
about it listen to what they had to say
FU
Palestine Palestine to my dick what do
you think the response should be from
Netanyahu and the military to God kill
all Palestinians all of them now one
left from The River To The Sea Palestine
will be deceased and Israel need to do
like this you see now Gaza like this
Gaza need to do like this oh oh like
this but all this Jewish two options
what do you what do you think the
response should beaza we got to wipe
them off the [__] map I'm talking
about every [__] platin them like a
parking lot yeah plat in the M
once nothing else you can do they they
prove to they prove to us that there's
nothing else you can do we tried and we
tried everything it doesn't work we have
to wipe them flat off the [__] map
like like a [__] parking lot I'm not
stopping till all Arabs are wiped out I
think I think now it's the time that we
need to race Gaza there is people inside
our people inside that kidnapped and now
we need to kill all of them and free
Israel all all of their belief is
killing Jewish and killing and murder
our people flatten it flatten Gaza that
will be the last war in Gaza this will
be yes so guys you saw that for yourself
just imagine for a second if myself as a
public figure anyone for that matter was
to utter words of support of Hamas we
are told now that in the UK if we were
to fly a Palestinian flag or if I was to
wear a t-shirt a palestin a Palestinian
t-shirt this could be seen as if I am
supporting what Hamas has done that is
how it is and you can see the stands and
hypocrisy where are the freedom speech
holders where are those who are
Advocates of freedom of speech every
single one of them will be quiet now it
shows you that there's double standards
and hypocrisy you can clearly see the
hatred they have to the Palestinians
they do not even see them as human
beings just like Hitler and how and what
he did to the Jewish people who were
massacred in the millions and we condemn
that and we condemn the killing of any
innocent being for that matter Jewish
Christian Muslim Hindu whatever it is
but you do not see the same thing from
their side they are outrightly literally
call calling for two solutions that that
guy said number one either Gaza is going
to be all Jewish settlers or it has to
be wiped out the dehumanization of the
Palestinians is very categorically clear
and the double standards of the media of
Palestinians were Palestinians die for
some reason they die but when it's the
Israeli they are killed but Palestinians
they die they don't get killed they die
but the Israelis they just get killed
hypocrisy and double standards I just
wanted to share that with you guys
inshallah brothers and sisters please
share this video and let the whole world
see that how some of these individuals
are getting scot-free if I was to do
that my door would be broken down the
very same day my channel will be shut
down my accounts would be frozen I would
be arrested for dehumanizing or for
anti-Semitism but when it's a
Palestinian their blood is cheap a
Muslims blood is cheap but no problem
like the prophet told us and I'll end on
this note this life is a prison for a
Believer it's a prison but brothers and
sisters just know it's not Eternal Abode
be patient stick firm to the Rope of
Allah subhana wa tala and like Allah
subhana says they will not fight you
except in fortified tows because they
are cowards asalam
Alay Islam net is raising funds to
establish a Masjid and community Center
in Norway and they urgently need your
support every person who prays there
every kid that learns about Islam every
youngster that memorize the Quran all of
this and so much more can be on your
scale of Good Deeds click the link and
donate what you can and share the video
for even extra reward